le Cercle d'Escrime Orléanais existe
depuis 1943 mais alors attention c'est
pas n'importe quel cercle ici c'est le
PSG de l'escrime ce cercle accueille
l'élite les escrimeurs français qui
manient le sabre et l'épée avec grâce et
élégance c'est à dire c'est pas comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on l'appelle
je suis dans la salle d'armes Christian
doriola qui accueille chaque année des
Champions et futurs champions qui
s'entraînent sans relâche afin de
remporter titre et médailles et
d'ailleurs je vais de ce pas à la
rencontre de Rémi garrigues Rémi
garrigues un jeune sabreur qui va devoir
affronter
la balle de Loire muchacha
un peu long ton nom là non oui mais
c'est pas fini
[Musique]
des pistes tu as vu c'est des pistes
métalliques c'est ce que tu retrouves en
compète donc en vrai c'est parfait pour
se préparer et en gros on vient ici
parce que si c'est l'endroit le plus
chaud pour les anciens l'endroit le plus
chaud ça veut dire que c'est ici que ça
se passe alors Rémi explique-moi un
petit peu les bases là donc je sais pas
déjà si tu connais la position de base
alors non il y a pas un truc comme ça
c'est comme ça en gros tu mets ta jambe
forte devant moi je suis droitier voilà
c'est ça et ta jambe gauche elle est en
perpendiculaire avec ta jambe droite en
gros pour aller vers l'avant tu vas
faire des marches donc tu vas faire
c'est ça et en gros pour reculer la même
chose dans l'inverse elle a l'air donc
c'est la jambe arrière qui recule ouais
c'est ça et en gros le but c'est de
toucher en premier mais il y a des rides
de convention donc ta parade d'attaquer
10 fois d'affilée ça veut dire que si tu
rates ton attaque et qu'après on touche
tous les deux c'est moi qui gagne le
point est-ce qu'il y a un truc genre tu
recules tu as perdu euh ouais ah tu vois
ça c'est la zone d'avertissement donc
quand tu passes les deux pieds derrière
la dernière ligne ici ouais tu es sorti
avant de commencer le combat quels sont
tes objectifs et tes rêves l'objectif
ultime c'est d'aller au jeu faire une
médaille au jeu tu vois c'est parti pour
l'affrontement
[Musique]
je suis pas ton père je sais t'inquiète
moi je suis prêt
[Musique]
il faut que tu viennes me toucher quoi
OK
[Musique]
je voulais quand même savoir avant de te
quitter tes titres à toi tes champions
mais tu es champion de quoi tu as déjà
des médailles et tout toi ouais j'ai
gagné une Coupe du monde cette année
juni et l'année dernière j'avais été 3e
en championnat d'Europe bon bah ça va ça
s'est pas trop mal passé
je sais pas où est-ce que j'ai foutu mon
sabre